I was convicted of murder when I was a young girl.
I have been an inmate for 15 long years
If there has been a crime, people want a guilty person.
Rightly or wrongly... does not matter.
You've given up hope of being set free?
I saved my hopes for smaller matters
I live in hopes of having a better breakfast tomorrow than I had today.
I am a doctor. I work with the mind.
It is not a question of your guilt or innocence that concerns me.
I simply wish to know what you yourself can actually remember.
I've lost part of my memory entirely.
My hope, sooner or later, we will bring back your memory.
I'm not at all sure I want it back
When I close my eyes
I can remember every detail of that house
The same sort of work from dawn to dusk
Always a mistress ordering me about.
- I'd like you to scrub this floor.
You stupid whore!
Strange to reflect that of all the people living in that house,
I was the only one of them left alive in six months time.
Have you developed your own theories regarding her sanity?
She could be a true amnesiac.
Or... simply guilty.
You are surrounded by dangers here.
Grace said she heard Death speak to her.
Let me in...
(Scream)
Let...
Me...
In.
(Scream)
They thought you could find answers.
It is knowledge of me you crave, doctor.
Knowledge with a lurid glare to it.
Knowledge gained through a descent into the pit.
You want to go where I can never go.
How can I be a murderer?